whole building's in the whole spirit of
christmas i love this time of year
it's a great time of year and uh i
actually you know in the spirit
of giving i thought that i would uh
you know give to the people of new york
since yeah the rest of the year i i i
pretty actively don't give a damn about
anybody
probably but myself right you're you're
a taker not a giver i certainly pretty
much year round but but you
but you decided recently you're gonna
you're gonna give i make up for it uh
for you know a couple of days in
december
right for tax purposes yeah yeah so i
thought
um like i said i would i would do
something nice for the people in new
york
and i took a camera crew with me and
with your permission
yes i'd like to show it to the folks at
home let's take a look at
this is andy bringing goodwill to the
people of new york right let's take a
look at this
hi i'm here on 4th street in manhattan
the other day i was at macy's and i
noticed that the line
to talk to santa it was like two hours
long and
there's not that many santas around not
that many businesses have santa's macy's
sort of has a
santa monopoly and i think that's wrong
so i thought if the people don't have
time to come to santa
why don't we take santa to the people so
i thought we take santa around to
different businesses that
don't normally have santas and uh we
we brought our santa here our own nipsy
russell he's
already popular yes indeed so we're
gonna try uh first with pharmacy
university pharmacy and uh we'll see how
it goes
merry christmas
i don't really see any kids in the store
i mean would adults be okay with you
yeah i thought right all right they're
not too heavy they can sit on my lap all
right
i'll try and get some light people
so um
excuse me um
merry christmas we've got nipsy russell
over there playing santa claus
would you like to maybe you know santa
tell santa what you want for christmas
you don't want to no no you got any
christmas bread
plants oh i have no no christmas plans
no you got any family to spend it with
or no no no i'm gonna be flying through
the air in a sled
oh oh right yeah
nipsey you're talking to me you don't
have to play yeah
well i know that i got no family to be
okay
gotta hang out
have a high holiday with the emphasis on
the word high
oh nipsy let's see what we got down the
street
you get a lot of kids in here no i don't
would you like to sit on santa's lap and
tell them what you want for christmas
help us know we're from late night with
conan o'brien this is nipsy rasola how
are you doing
we're just bringing uh santa claus
around to different
businesses oh no customers
no do you want to talk to santa
oh thanks all right
well thanks maybe you'd like to have
nipsy russell be your santa claus and
how about you think about missing
something uh well he could come in with
a chair and set it up and
when kids come in they could sit down
just like they do at macy's and
and tell santa what they want for
christmas so what are we gonna get
you're gonna get uh christmas
joy christmas good feelings
come on tell them santa well i don't
know but maybe you want kwanzaa instead
of christmas
i mean what are we going to get from
this if we getting any credit is still
never going to be mentioned on this so
sure what's the name of the store that's
what i mean
what's the name of your store
[Music]
we'll mention the name of your store and
then people will come all next year and
buy their gifts from you
all right oh that's sad what's in it for
me
[Music]
wait i see a kid let's get him
there's two kids in a stroller
this is what we've been waiting for
what's your name sweetheart
mom you don't have your name what's the
ian
oh her name is anne hi his name ian
ian oh that's that's a he it's got more
hair than the [ __ ] the greatest sound
you'll ever hear is little kids in their
toys
children were sent from heaven because
the lord couldn't stand that noise
santa made a joke
oh this looks interesting
uh yeah and we'll give this place a shot
bring santa's throne here here we are
there you go all good girls come and see
santa
something nice for mrs claus that would
be nice for mrs claus there you go
and uh you have no claws drawers
all right now this is okay these ladies
want to talk to santa claus
we got santa's helpers here how very
nice
we're closing i'll just be
[Music]
good night good night
[Music]
very nice job and our thanks to nipsy
too
for helping us out we uh
that woman at the end who the hell was
that uh she worked in the store
all right she was very uh more later yes
we'll take a little break right now and
when we uh when we come back the oz man
cometh ozzy osbourne